[Musique]
pense que j'en suis vraiment rendu
compte de ses revers 13 14 ans c'était
arrivé comme en une nuit
non c'était passé brutale je me sujet ça
se fait tout ça ne suis jamais vraiment
posé la question peut-on premier tableau
mon premier tableau non le premier
souvenir que j'ai c'est un truc très
très anciens c'est un espace de bonhomme
ethan verte et ça ça devrait vraiment
j'étais tout petit il y avait déjà deux
dans les trucs que tu avais plus tard
oui parce que j'y repense souvent donc
c'est que la guerre les gens je trouve
que les adultes romans je trouve que
c'est dire qu'avec un projet peut être
leur envoyer de swatch manquant pas de
savon du coni en plus oui énormément
je vais exploser à quel âge 784,4 milles
cannes j'avais 27 ans 27 40
31 faire compte pas sur moi pour faire
la soustraction l'addition dans ce qu'on
fait qu'est ce qui t'a le plus influencé
mais primitifs italiens ouais
puis j'ai toujours une passion pour
nicolas pouces et
j'ai eu une période j'étais vraiment
tres tres quand j'avais 17 ans et n
giacometti peron la franchise qui a
évidemment horizontaux passionnément
tous les grands
il ya des gens qui sont aussi un contre
les artistes l'art brut c'est quelqu'un
que tu aurais aimé être dans l'histoire
dans l'histoire de l'air dans l'histoire
de la peinture
si ce n'était pas elle-même enfin bon
bon je dire avant le talent du génie de
picasso évidemment sinon je sais bien
que j'ai pas le choix je peux me poser
la question à laon picasso évidemment
des copiés déjà des gens qui me bat
j'espère au moins toute façon je pense
que imiter c'est pas un peu genre hâtif
ou si elles sont bien sûr les gens qui
aiment essayer des trucs
oui c'est ça la justice a que je vois je
vois pas la chose de façon négative mais
je pense quoi je vais pas la prétention
penser que déjà des gens entendent
s'inscrire parce que je pense à ta tête
tu pense avoir apporté quoi la facture
je sais pas ce que j'apporte quelque
chose à la peinture à moi la personne
qui porte son nom
tout ce dont j'ai besoin enfin dans sa
complexité
et s'ils avaient une définition de toi
dans le dictionnaire des prêtres j'aurai
ce soit de quoi par exemple
hélène delprat de poing au les
guillemets quoi un delprat 1957 petit
tirer pour l'interrogation
j'espère un peu voilà c'est l'épitaphe
non je sais faire
je suis j'aimerais mieux qu'on puisse
pas définir tandis que j'ai fait de la
peinture africaines par exemple
certaines aires oui ça m'agace ça
m'agace parce qu'en même temps je le
comprends je suis en partie responsable
puisque j'ai fait pas mal de choses
aspirer les arts primitifs mais un
collectif s'est pas forcément l'afrique
c'est un peu schématique faut le crever
je vais combien de temps pour faire un
tableau ça peut être très rapide très
long je peux reprendre des choses
commençaient par à 0,85 à définir
maintenant je laisse dormir je reprends
j'écoute de la musique quand tu pars
mais jusqu'où tu foutais de l'opéra
l'opéra comme auteur plutôt mozart
abonnement qui fait des trucs à 100 mais
les primitifs à temps
ses parents
non c'était particulier savent combien
tableau de la mine el prat
comment tableau d'un maître sur un
maintenant je ne sais pas car dont la
connaissance je sais pas exactement où
je vis bien la peinture a toujours du
bien
j'avais créé sur internet personne tout
ce dont j'ai besoin à tout va la
peinture et 3 km en marchant comme tous
les marchands
maintenant il y en a qui disent que
c'est 70 je sais pas moi j'ai la chance
que ce soit 50%
et puis ça se passe très bien et c'est
normal
puisqu'il ya toutes les troupes pour les
catalogues les deux places fortes que
ces réseaux wi absolument absolue c'est
normal il faut un travail pour moi je
m'occupe strictement pas dans ce qui
s'appelle anthony mais votre précieux je
peins vous permet de peindre dans la
plus grande tranquillité c'est ça le
gros marché
on peut les voir ôter tableau
actuellement en ce moment la fiac
dentelle au stand b12 comme la vita
mienne un chien dryats mal et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu